it's a good song
we found something in our reporting
something happening here in the one big
city in Qatar
a place the whole world is looking at
right now
an invisible border drawn to trap human
beings to make them work to make them
build I want to show this to you so let
me take you back to show you how we
ended up sending a camera to someone and
teaching them how to shoot undercover in
Qatar while simultaneously capturing
interviews in rural Nepal and how I
ended up here staring for hours at Maps
drawn by the Qatari government all of
this to shine a light on something that
Qatar doesn't want the world to see all
of these have been emptied very recently
[Music]
hey I need to show you something I've
been looking at maps of Qatar because
the World Cup is going there when the
world is going to be fixated on one
place you got to look at all the maps
I've been on the government website of
Qatar looking at their zoning Maps this
is the city of Doha the capital of Qatar
but look at this the whole city is
yellow and there's this one little shape
of blue Doha Industrial Area I know
we're talking about zoning I think
something's up here I've been trying to
map this like throw it on like my other
tools to map it and see if there's like
what this could be and it's not totally
making sense it's kind of cut off from
the rest of the city there's another
municipality kind of in between it and
Doha but it's a part of Doha usually
when you have weird zoning like this
there's something going on since guitar
got awarded the World Cup in 2010
there's been all sorts of issues with
their labor conditions and all of that
and I think this has to do with that but
I don't totally know the World Cup is
happening in a few weeks I want to go to
this place I need to reach out to Cami
one of our research producers we're
going to dive into this we're going to
figure it out we're going to Doha folks
hey Cami I want to go to Qatar before
the World Cup to look at this one part
of the city that's completely zoned
differently I think it has to do with
like the labor situation there I can't
not print it I'm going
there we have to find a fixer local
producer someone on the ground who can
help us not get arrested I will follow
up tomorrow with more details going to
guitar
yes let's do it this sounds like a
really great story I'll happily go to
Doha with you I'll start researching
right now I'm going to guitar
congratulations I just want you to be
smart I've been doing some research and
I don't know how easy it's going to be
for us to film places especially in the
industrial area from what I've read
They're notoriously not very kind to
journalists
the best part about the golf is that
these cities are like so like cartoonish
this is a hotel in freaking Doha look at
this opening later this year can I stay
in this hotel that looks like a freaking
half pipe I've always wanted to do this
I've never had an excuse
still have fixer number one referred me
to someone else so fingers crossed that
Doha fixer number two is gonna work out
drones yes do you think they'll let me
fly my drone in uh Doha
why NATO countries are helping out
during anti-drunk stuff because they're
afraid of you know terrorist drones
coming in wait but what about just
just drowning or sending out anti-drones
wait what yeah okay not great news
archic sir hasn't found anybody in the
industrial area who wants to talk with
us it's not looking likely that they're
going to find anybody I'm going to keep
trying to connect with anyone on the
ground I think it's a hiding people
thing I don't know but I'm trying to
find a fixer to help me get in there
you're gonna go in there yes
I mean it's just it's not like some
Secrets you're supposed to be living in
a week and we haven't found any fixers
we haven't found any people on the
ground who could help us I'm just a bit
concerned of our timeline right now
[Music]
I think we found someone a fixer who is
deeply connected with the worker
population in Doha and is potentially
going to help us to get into the
industrial area we're meeting with him
on a call in a few minutes
nice to meet you how are you doing Ryan
let me switch off the AC did you get the
proposal that we sent over
we're not trying to get any secretive
footage it's more just about life in the
industrial area I guess my question for
you is like if I went into an industrial
era with my camera not a big crew but
just my camera had to go film what what
camera like this if I went into the
industrial area with this camera and
film another thing
you know uh explain that what do you
mean yeah
you'll get undue attention from who do
you think I would get under attention
arms are controlled by generating forces
and for example police so it's not very
smart for me to go filming around in
that area yeah okay and I think that's
why we want to figure out a way
it's my first time
what do you think
okay
[Music]
um
this is not happening
this is not happening it does if if we
can't do the shots then this story
doesn't work meaning I won't go to Doha
so it's pretty important for us to know
soon if this is feasible or if it's not
feasible is
can you um
[Music]
well it's really nice to meet you thank
you so much for chatting I can't safely
go into this Industrial Area like it's
now clear to me like every fixer has
just been like no this guy's just set up
Point Blank he's like you're a white
dude with a camera like this is this is
not safe it feels like if you go you're
just gonna what get shots of shiny
buildings and not actually gain access
yeah which I guess could be cool no I
mean there's an option here where you
try to find someone that could go in and
then if we could get like a camera
person in Nepal or Bangladesh or
somewhere where workers have been and
gone home we could totally
tell this story The World Cup is
literally a few weeks away I got some
work to do the new plan
find someone on the ground in Qatar
we'll go into
the industrial area and tell me why the
hell the government is so afraid of of
me going in with my camera
[Music]
before we continue I need to tell you
about something which is that today's
video is not sponsored by any brand
sometimes we do really deep dives into
complicated and sensitive topics it's
hard to find a sponsor when we make
stories like this I want to tell you
about a way that you can support what
we're doing if you're not interested in
hearing this pitch from me that's
totally fine so I'm gonna put a little
bar down here on the bottom of the
screen for the rest of you that are
still here thank you and I want to tell
you about The Newsroom The Newsroom is
our community on patreon which is more
and more turning into a place that I am
very excited about journalism is
changing and I'm making big bets that
the type of Journalism that will succeed
in the future is the type of Journalism
that dives deep without the need for a
journalistic institution to dictate what
direction we need to go I want the story
to guide me whatever way it takes me and
I'm allowed to do that because I'm here
on YouTube with all of you but doing
this form of Journalism on YouTube is
incredibly resource intensive behind the
scenes we have a lot of of people making
sure that we're factually accurate that
we are actually finding the best facts
possible it's hard and resource
intensive but I'm going to keep doing it
that's where you all come in for those
who are supporting over at The Newsroom
you allow us to do this kind of
Journalism but if that's not enough for
you we also have some really cool perks
including an extra video every month we
do a behind the scenes video every month
where we show you everything that is
happening all of the people and
personalities and processes that make
this stuff happen there are a lot of
really fun talented people making this
work possible you also get access to one
of my scripts every month and you get
access to some exclusive Tom fox tracks
Tom is our composer he makes Amazing
Music we will give you some of that
music royalty free for you to use
however you'd like and we'll ask the
community to vote on thumbnails and
titles and video ideas and I really
value having a smaller version of this
group here on YouTube but like over on
The Newsroom if you're not able to
support that's totally fine I appreciate
you being here in the first place at the
end of the day being here watching the
videos sharing them is a huge way that
this community allows me to do what I
can do to make better journalism so
that's my little pitch to you for those
interested and willing to support I want
to get back into this story and show you
how we ended up in this situation
Qatar is a tiny super rich country in
the desert and it sits on the largest
known natural gas field on Earth since
they're Independence in 1970 Qatar got
really rich really fast leapfrogging the
normal Economic Development process that
countries go through as they grow
usually as a country gets Rich
immigrants from poorer neighboring
countries migrate in to take lower
paying jobs required to keep the economy
growing construction Hospitality manual
labor caretaking Food Services you know
what I mean every rich country
experiences this but in Qatar all of
their neighbors were also getting super
rich super fast so they started looking
elsewhere for cheap labor and soon there
was a flow of people taking these jobs
but there's a tension here thanks to all
this abundant oil and gas money the
Qatari government provides a luxurious
welfare state to their citizens free
health care education guaranteed jobs
subsidized housing and literally they
just get paychecks for being Qatari for
winning the fossil fuel jackpot so Qatar
needed labor from other countries but
they didn't want to let these immigrants
in on the Sumptuous benefits of their
welfare state so they started using this
system where employers could sponsor
workers to come to Qatar to work they
wouldn't be citizens or anything close
to it they would be totally at the mercy
of their employer this was called the
kafala system and it was the foundation
upon which Qatar built its country
[Music]
the winner
is Qatar
so this is giant moment it's I mean I
made a whole video about how this
happened I'm not going to go into it but
the fact is that as soon as Qatar won
the World Cup
they had a lot of work to do
because their country didn't have a lot
of infrastructure basically any
infrastructure at all to host this thing
so wait why were they chosen to host the
World Cup if they didn't have an
infrastructure it's a long story again I
made an entire video about it the fact
is they needed to build a bunch of stuff
in a very short time so what they
basically did is just ramp up the system
that they already had importing tons of
Labor from South Asia and Africa to come
build their country in this case to
build infrastructure for the World Cup
[Music]
so yeah I've been deep in the context in
the history and the data for all of this
the stuff I can do from the office but
the fact is time is running out I need
to find someone on the ground someone in
Doha someone in Bangladesh or Nepal who
can help me capture what is actually
happening in these places talk to the
people there I've been planting lots of
seeds and some of them are starting to
sprout so we're getting closer we're
getting closer
hey I've been talking with a journalist
in Nepal who's really great and can
connect us with workers who've returned
home he's done a lot of work on this and
he can go out and shoot these interviews
I finally just settling into the fact
that I'm not going to Doha and I'm
disappointed in that because I wanted to
be on the ground I wanted to see this
issue but the right choices to use those
resources to engage camera people to go
capture the right stories in different
parts of the world and that's what we're
gonna do luckily I've got Instagram I
also have miso soup
hey Sandra um thanks so much for
reaching I really appreciate it I'm
doing this deep dive on the world cup
and put a call out for people in Doha to
help me out here I was gonna be going to
Qatar and it's going to be there next
week and I'm not going and now looking
for people on the ground to help me and
as always a bunch of people responded I
live in a world where I can just ask for
things and there's such a supportive
Community who wants to help with these
stories which is just an amazing reality
probably 15 20 hours over the next two
weeks getting some shots can I
officially you know hire you as a
contractor to do this and again all of
this is 100 Anonymous we will make sure
that you everyone is safe
Bingo yes yes yes I am talking to
somebody in Qatar who is a journalist
who wants to help me out is excited oh
my God I feel so much better there was
someone in Doha who has camera skills
with language skills because journalism
skills who's excited to help and is just
ready to go oh my gosh nice to meet you
hello how are you doing yeah everything
is great really appreciate you just like
harnessing the the energy on this and
just being super down and they have
access to the industrial area
yes I want you to tell me how
comfortable you feel about this process
in terms of Safety and Security what's
sensitive what's not just give me an
overview of where some red lines are
here I found someone in Doha who I could
give a camera to to film we're gonna
call him Raj we won't be showing his
face we'll change his voice because he
could get in deep trouble for this first
things first everything is monitored or
like obedience works everywhere in this
country no matter where I film I'm also
being filmed specifically come to an
industrial area there are a few layers
to what we can do and what we cannot do
and over the next several weeks of
talking to Raj I realized that my
fixation on this one blue square isn't
actually the full story it's just the
beginning
I plan to go on every street and film
from inside the car and I think that's
the safest way to film and get like the
value of what is implied to get inside
the city
we have someone on the ground with a
camera that we bought them I've lined
them out on how to shoot undercover I
actually wanted to ask you like how do
you get along shooting footages without
getting loaded the key to filming
without being seen is to look elsewhere
you're holding this thing like you're
holding a an ice cream cone you're
walking around and you're looking
elsewhere and then you just smoothly you
know put it away and you just get really
comfortable with turning on and off
they're going to the industrial area
they are very very cautious for a very
good reason I would like you to shoot in
60 frames a second I'd like you to shoot
in 4k this is going to be an amazing
story if we can pull it off
the government of Qatar is way more
insane than I expected and we're going
to take a lot of precautions to keep
everyone safe we're going to show
the world what Qatar doesn't want the
world to see
so I'm taking them over
[Music]
it should be like one and a half hour
right Raj was finally heading to the
industrial area to show us exactly what
this place was but it wasn't until we
heard from the people who had worked
there and lived there that we began to
see how deep this trap really was
today is the day in Nepal A Million
Miles Away they have been shooting
interviews look these are people who
actually worked on the World Cup
stadiums and are now back home in Nepal
you start to get to the human side of it
and it becomes way less theoretical it's
way less about these zoning maps and
stuff and it becomes about real humans
and this is where it starts to get heavy
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as we've been setting up all these
Logistics and figuring all of this out
we've also been reporting and
investigating the bigger context here
the industrial area this little blue
shape on the map is actually just one of
several mechanisms that the Qatari
government uses to bring people over to
their country to trap them there and
then to exploit them to work to build
all the things they want them to build
let me show you
okay so it's 2010 Qatar just won the
World Cup big they have to build an
unfathomable amount of infrastructure in
a very short time they do this by paying
a bunch of people to go to these
countries to small villages in places
like Bangladesh and Paul to recruit a
bunch of workers to come to Qatar to
build and this is the first phase of
what I'm calling the guitar trap because
it is here where these workers were told
they had to pay a recruitment fee
usually like one to four thousand
dollars just to like get recruited to go
to Qatar and work these people don't
have one to four thousand dollars lying
around so they often would borrow money
from family or take out a loan with
really high interest rates so even
before they start working they start
their relationship with work and Qatar
with debt so now you have workers from
Bangladesh India Nepal all over this
region flooding into Qatar to start
building as this is happening Qatar
implements a law
this is a law that's meant to protect
families okay the law says that worker
groups are not allowed to live within
quote family areas in the city of Doha
it's a little ambiguous well the
government later clarified that what
they're referring to is Bachelors people
in the Qatar that are single men okay so
these Bachelors can't live in family
zones where are these family zones that
Bachelors can't live in is it just like
one little part of the city no to
clarify they released a map
it looks like this
everything in yellow is a family Zone a
place where Bachelor workers are not
allowed to live if you project it onto
like a real map you will see that this
is the entire city basically and then
they reserved one little plot of land a
city away still zoned for Doha this
little blue shape where these Bachelor
workers can live oh but they made a few
exceptions anyone who works at like
markets and barber shops restaurants oh
and white collar professionals who are
Bachelors can also stay in the family
zones so really these working Bachelors
is just a euphemism for guys who look
like this guys who are there doing
construction who Qatar does not want to
see in their shiny downtown area so they
reserved them a spot out here in the
desert next to the sewage Pond this is
the map that sent me down the rabbit
hole and now I see it for what it is I
knew something was up I looked at a
bunch of these zoning Maps they're using
this to put the people that they don't
want to see in the places that will
never be seen
so now these guys are already Laden with
debt because of the recruiting fees and
now they're relegated and trapped into
this part of the city the part of the
city that I was not allowed to go to
without getting arrested this is where
Raj is on his way to this is where we're
getting footage from
here
these kind of accommodations where
workers live
this is one of those buses that the
workers that live in the initial area
used to commute
today is Friday and it's a Leisure day
for a lot of workers as you can see a
lot of clothes that have been washed and
left in the sun to be dry
this is the industrial area it's the
thing I've been thinking about for a
very long time and I'm finally seeing
the footage from inside and I have to
say it's not
anything super surprising this is kind
of anticlimactic in the sense that I'm
just looking at like a kind of Dusty
dilapidated part of town with a bunch of
buildings that look the same and yet I
now know a lot more about what this
place represents look at this the
industrial area isn't just far away it's
completely cut off here's the Metro
System brand new that they were planning
to build for the World Cup this is the
whole system connects all of the
stadiums in the city you can see that
they planned a couple of these lines to
go out to the industrial area this would
connect the industrial area to the city
and yet these lines aren't actually
built they're going to start on these
right after the World Cup is over so
yeah this place is just like completely
disconnected I think I now see that and
it's not just disconnected
unintentionally this is very
systematically intentionally
disconnected from the rest of the city
our interviews in Nepal gave us some
clarity on what it's like to live out
there
[Music]
the next phase of the Qatar trap has to
do with how these people were exploited
how their rights were taken away from
them to force them to work
to build the World Cup these workers
were forced to work in very horrible
conditions look at the temperatures in
Doha in the summer getting close to 50
degrees Celsius close to 120 degrees
Fahrenheit they literally have
air-conditioned outdoor spaces look at
that air conditioning outside on Wheels
the stadiums themselves will have air
conditioning and if these workers are
out there doing like manual labor in
this heat is
foreign
a lot of workers report being treated
like animals being yelled at and bossed
around in totally inhumane ways foreign
Behind These Walls the conditions that
these people were made to live in and
really given no choice on where they
could live are horrendous
journalists and human rights
organizations have actually gotten
cameras back here to actually show what
that looks like the Heat and conditions
got so bad for some workers that they
never returned home
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thousands of totally healthy young men
died
while working in these conditions we'll
likely never know the true cause of
death because instead of a real
investigation the Qatari authorities
come out and use these vague
classifications like heart failure and
natural causes as the cause of death
doing this robs the family of answers on
why their loved one came home in a box
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so if these employers are so bad why
don't these employees just change jobs
the answer is they can't for a long time
legally they couldn't because the next
part of this trap has to do with
paperwork
[Music]
oftentimes this paperwork would
stipulate that these workers can't
change jobs without the permission of
their employers so the status of these
workers who were trapped in their little
blue box on the outskirts of the city
was completely at the mercy of their
employers if they left their job they
would be considered a foreign immigrant
illegally there and could be arrested
and put into jail
just one more layer of the Trap and then
there was the fact that these employers
would often not pay their workers for
months at a time withholding wages from
them and thus increasing their leverage
and power over them and with no recourse
these workers couldn't do anything about
it so yes we're now talking about forced
labor with no compensation a euphemism
for modern day slavery I know that
sounds dramatic but that's literally
what is happening here not to all
workers there were workers who had great
conditions and got paid on time but this
system enabled firms to so deeply
exploit workers because it gave them so
much power over them and so little
recourse for these workers to complain
or do anything without being punished or
arrested so with no other options some
workers turned to their last resort
protesting
foreign
[Music]
don't be fooled here this wasn't some
worker Uprising this type of thing is
illegal in Qatar an authoritarian police
state where assembly like this is
totally not okay so what happened is the
police would show up squashy's protests
tell them that everything was going to
be okay and they would get paid and then
deported a huge number of these people
got them out of the system so that the
status quo could remain just
dehumanizing people that belong to a
certain race
and are brought here for certain
purposes is not justified by any means
thanks to International scrutiny Qatar
started to make some reforms I realized
this wasn't going to fly if they were
going to host the World Cup so they
started instituting things like worker
hours that were not in the heat of the
day mandatory water on site so these
people could stay hydrated a minimum
wage changing the law so that people
could technically change jobs without
permission compensating families for
people who died working all of this
looked great on paper but human rights
organizations like Amnesty International
actually have looked to see if those
policies have trickled into reality and
you know what I'm going to say they
haven't
this is
walls
and don't people live here as well
[Music]
so yeah I really understand now what
this little blue box is for what it
represents the authorities in Doha are
getting ready for this world cup and as
the event approaches they are making
sure that anyone who belongs in this box
stays in that box
okay this is insane the timing of this
this is literally happening right now
been wiped out by some weird phenomenon
I just got a message from Raj that
um they are evicting workers from the
city people who are living in the yellow
area illegally because of the law are
being evicted it's a couple weeks before
the World Cup and so the timing is not
surprising that they are cracking down
almost everywhere
yeah
everything looks like it has been done
really quick officially catching people
and putting them into Shanaya which is
the initial area I'm trying to get
footages of them being evicted because a
lot of them are being evicted like just
with two hours of notice that's what I'm
trying to do now this is so clear to me
what's happening they're clearly
starting to really enforce this like
family zoning thing to get anyone who
they don't want to be seen out of the
center of the city I've never done a
story like this before this is
developing like day by day and all of
this reporting that we've done I'm now
seeing it play out in in real time as
the city prepares for the world cup
using all of these laws to continue to
hide these people to get them out of
view as all of these International
visitors prepare to come it feels so
empty and it's only the small houses
that have been evacuated
okay well we got to the bottom of it
we know why this exists
the way it's drawn what it means who
it's for what it's meant to do
I did not expect that I know what's
happening behind those walls how those
people are trapped how their families
miss them and how some of them might
never come home
foreign
[Music]
now let's be clear this happened well
before the World Cup ever came to Qatar
and what I fear is that once we all move
on once these few weeks of playing
football are over we'll forget about
everything we saw the guitar will have
no incentive to actually do anything
about this and they'll go back to what
they've been doing for decades deceiving
these workers trapping them in their
country exploiting them and then hiding
them from View
thank you
[Music]